and the war in Ukraine much of the focus
remains on the battle for the eastern
city of bakmuc Ukraine's Army says
Russian forces have made some gains
there recently amid bloody fighting Remy
and socino visited the front lines in
the northeastern City Northeastern
region of kharkiv where Ukrainian army
unit controls an area once held by
Russian troops
challenge
Far From Any holes of power these walls
of Earth protect Ukraine's Brave
fighters of the 209th battalion
war-hearted watching the front line I
will hate Russians for the rest of my
life Lieutenant Lord his call sign has
fought since day one when Russians came
to my home the only way it had to be
done is to fight back
Russia invaded the harkeeb region in the
war's first days shattering families
Ukraine pushed them back to the Border
half a year later now Russia's new
threat to move nuclear weapons into
Belarus hangs over the zero line with
Russian forces just over the horizon the
soldiers we spoke to said that they
think Vladimir Putin is an old man
throwing yet more empty threats
it's just blackmail said this Sergeant
Grandpa forgot to take his pills said
another soldiers rotate in for three to
five days enjoying few human Comforts
trying to keep warm through freezing
nights
the 209th has crisscrossed the country
in battle
I try to keep my Humanity I just want to
finish and go home have a wife have a
child with an expected Ukrainian
counter-offensive they say Ukraine will
win this war their front lines a shield
for democracy around the world for CBS
mornings raymie inocencio on Ukraine's
Harkey front line with Russia